space agency's project scientist for
this mission
remco charou the umetsat project
scientist for sentinel 6 michael
freilich
josh willis of nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory
nasa project scientist for this mission
deidra byrne oceanographer at noaa
and lastly luanne thompson a university
of washington
oceanographer who is part of the science
team
a reminder to the media you can ask
question by pressing star
one for anyone watching who would like
to submit a question
you can do so by using the seeing the
seas
hashtag we will begin with nasa's earth
science division director karen
st jermaine welcome karen
thank you so much marina it is great to
be here i could not be more excited
for our launch coming up tomorrow um
sentinel six michael freilich launch is
exciting to me for
really three reasons the first is
uh of course it's my first launch as the
nasa earth science director
but perhaps more importantly is the
impact
this uh this satellite is going to have
on our understanding of our earth system
and the third reason is really the
people behind
this mission and what it took to make it
happen
so let me start with the with the impact
this mission is going to have
now our our earth is a system
of intricately connected dynamics
between
land ocean ice atmosphere
and also of course our human communities
and
and that system is changing and and
because
70 of the earth's surface is is ocean
the oceans play an enormous role in how
the whole system changes
and these these global changes are of
course
creating both risks and opportunities
for our human communities
and at nasa what we do is we use that
the vantage point of space to get a
global view
of of the earth and and in this case
sentinel 6 michael freilick is going to
give us a global view
of the sea surface height we will use
that
along with our models and our predictive
capability
to really understand how the changing
sea level
is going to impact communities coastal
communities
and weather worldwide as i'll you'll see
in this
uh in this next chart here sentinel 6
michael freilich is the newest addition
to the nasa fleet and you'll see that
many of
the uh the satellites in the nasa fleet
were developed collaboratively with
international
partners and that's that's important
because the challenges we're facing are
truly global and it's and it's taking
a coordinated effort around the world in
space agencies to make all the
observations
we need to make to understand how our
our climate
is changing the sentinel 6 michael
freilich
will continue a nearly 30-year record
along with its its twin that will launch
a few years later
we'll continue our record of sea surface
height observation
well into uh the next decade
it's it's a it's a it's a critical
observation
for a number of reasons but it's its
power is
really unleashed when we combine
our altimetry observations or the sea
surface height measurements
with the observations we get from the
other satellites in the nasa fleet and
the international fleet
in the next chart you'll see that it's
really when we combine
altimetry observations with
observations from our gravity missions
and so forth
that we can not only see that the sea
level is rising
and that's the the top curve you see on
this chart but we can also tell
how much of that change is coming from
melting ice sheets and glaciers
and how much of that change is coming
from thermal expansion of the oceans
themselves in other words when the
oceans warm
they expand so the middle chart here
about two-thirds
of the the sea level rise that we're
seeing is due to the
melting ice sheets and glaciers and
one-third is due to that expansion
so that's the kind of power we get in
when we combine
observations another is
when we talk about hurricanes and
and tropical storms
so sea level rise or or sea level
observations can tell us where there's
warm water
in in in our oceans and this is
particularly important this year as
we're seeing a
record-breaking hurricane season in the
atlantic
when when a tropical storm passes over
warm water
we can expect that it may rapidly
intensify
and that's really critical for warning
our coastal communities
and and we get that when we combine the
altimetry observations
with our weather satellites so it's this
combination it's this fleet
that's observing the entire earth system
that really gives us
the insight into how the whole earth
system
is changing i mentioned partners
and and this uh this partnership with
issa
is is a first for us at this level in
the earth science division within nasa
and it's been a terrific experience this
team has worked through all the
challenges of covid
to get us to where we are one day before
launch
this is also a special mission for me
because
mike freilich's name is is is on the
side of this satellite
mike was my predecessor is the earth
science
director he was also a leader in the
field
a mentor and a friend to many of us and
uh and so it's an extra special day when
we see
when we will see this satellite launch
the satellite that he worked so hard
to uh to put in place so
it's a great weekend for a launch and
we're looking forward to it and
i'm going to pass off now to my good
friend
dr craig donilon who's the esa project
scientist
craig thanks karen uh
could have the first slide please i
think we both agree that earth from
space is beautiful
i mean it's glory and it's technical or
is seen in this copernicus ii
image of arie atoll in the republic of
the maldives
i mean in one picture both the majesty
and the fragility of our world is
revealed
but sea level rise is a direct threat to
the very existence of ariato
and it also threatens major cities with
increased flooding
including new york london amsterdam
tokyo and more
it's estimated that about two to three
million more people are exposed
for every one centimeter rise in sea
level next slide please
as you mentioned our earth system is
changing the dynamic balance that has
persisted
for before the industrial revolution has
been upset by
the almost instantaneous combustion of
huge reserves
of carbon as our society has developed
and we see evidence of this dramatic
change in many different measurements
and events around the world
but they all point in the same direction
the earth is warming
and the greatest indicator of this earth
system imbalance is sea level rise
it's because it integrates the total
impact of global warming
that's dominated by the ice sheets
melting the thermal expansion of the sea
water and
changes in the terrestrial water storage
next slide please
as karen mentioned sea level rise is not
the same
everywhere and rather than relying on a
few local tide gauges dotted around the
walls coastlines
we need a global tide gauge in space to
monitor the complexity of what's going
on
and collect evidence of these changes to
make the best decisions for our future
world
based on scientific evidence next slide
please
now sentencing michael freilick is a new
satellite to do
just this with enhanced continuity
compared to the previous missions that
have flown in this orbit
we have a brand new synthetic aperture
radar altimeter
and a microwave radiometer that really
are at the heart of the mission
measuring c surface height reference to
the same datums as the
global positioning satellites that are
used in your in your smartphones
and many people ask about the shape of
this spacecraft our little house in
space
well sentinel 6 has a design heritage in
the european space agency cryosat
satellite
and this allows us to put solar panels
directly on the side of the satellite
limiting the need for big solar wings
that have to
move and that makes for a very stable
satellite design
which is really important for a
satellite ultimate emission
next slide please now to make the
measurements
the satellite uses a razor a radar pulse
that's sent down and reflected off
the sea surface and we time um the the
the time
of that travel and return and we would
see we receive a waveform
and from this waveform we can determine
the c surface height from the radar
range
the significant wave height from the
slope of the leading edge
and the wind speed from the surface
roughness of the waves on the ocean and
people will talk about that a bit later
and the timing arrangement that we have
on board the spacecraft allows us to
exploit the doppler characteristics of
the
radar allowing us to bring a whole bunch
of measurements together at the same
point on the earth's surface
and average those and at the same time
reduce the
long track resolution of the instrument
to just about 300 meters which is
compared to two kilometers from previous
missions pretty good
we can do both the low resolution and
the higher resolution mode at the same
time which is really important
because by introducing new technology
into the time series
we don't want to destabilize that time
series so we need to look at both types
of measurements the old ones and the new
and in order to get our accurate
measurements of sea level rise we
average data
over about a 10 day period taking all of
the measurements over the global ocean
to give us a sea surface height from
which we can then compute
sea level rise next slide please
now copernicus is the world's largest
operational earth observation system
it's implemented by the european space
agency on behalf of the european
commission
together with umeza and it includes a
fleet of complementary satellites
working together in synergy
particularly with ocean models and
allowing us to do
and and ocean forecasting but
these work like a painting each
additional color
that we can use to paint a wonderful
scientific picture of the earth
but michael frielek goes further and
this really leverages a special and
unique
relationship between nasa noaa umitzat
and the european space as you can see
together with the european commission
and it really follows the collaborative
principles championed by michael fralick
himself
and so tonight all of the dedicated
mission teams working around the world
are really looking forward to the launch
of michael freilick it's going to be a
new star in the sky allowing us to
deliver the best quality measurements of
sea level rise
ocean waves and winds to make the best
decisions today
for everybody in the future so i'll hand
over now to uh renko shirou from
umitzat who's uh the human site mission
scientist ramco
to you thank you craig
well copernicus sentinel 6 mission is
going to be very exciting for unicef
it's actually the first ultimate radar
temperature mission that human sound has
been leading from the start
we have designed and set up the ground
segment
and our processing chain and now we are
ready
in a few days from now to take over the
operation of the sentinel 6 satellite
then we will download the first data
from the satellite
and we will from that create the most
accurate
sea level wave height and wind speed
measurements
ever similar six as
craic already shown fits nicely into
this constellation of copenicus missions
apart from sentinel 6 there are actually
two
other satellites with altimeters on
boards
for 703 a and sample 3b first slide
please
those satellites are also operated by
human sets
from here in darmstadt and these are
very complementary missions
as you can see in the slides the
purplish
colored ground tracks are very dense
they are those from the channel 3a
and 703b and they can observe the
smaller scale
features like ocean eddies
sentinel 6 continues the heritage of 30
years of its predecessors making a more
coarse pattern here in white
it will focus on the larger skill
features
like el nino and it will very accurately
trace sea level rise both globally
and regionally after launch
we will have a year of commissioning
that focuses
on running the processors
and analyzing the data that we
have processed we will check the
measurements together with our partner
agencies
but also with a number of experts in the
field
we can compare the data to ocean models
but most importantly we can compare it
to its predecessor
json3 and to facilitate that the two
satellites
will be flying only 30 seconds apart on
the same orbit
that means that they will basically see
the same ocean conditions
and that of course makes comparing the
measurements much better
and as craig already indicated because
we have also a new technology
this is very important that we'll do
this for a whole year to make sure
that we have a full continuity
once we are confident that all the data
is good then we will send it
to all of the users
this will include meteorological
agencies
signed users but also anybody who is
interested in the data
as soon or as long as you have an
internet connection
you can get the data for free
now after that year of commissioning
seminal 6 will become the reference
mission
that means it's the reference for all
other
altimeters for sea level
wave height and wind speed
now json3 is then available to be moved
in a slightly
different orbit it can for example
just like the previous missions
then be retired into a slightly
different orbit
where it can do something else for
example map
the sea service very accurately in a
very dense pattern and
very high detail and since the sea
surface maps
after the graffiti field it actually
highlights
sea mounts and
troughs and also ridges
deep below the ocean surface
and scientists have been able to use
this data to make a very detailed
global map of the sea bottom
still we know the topography of the moon
better
than our own ocean bottom
and still thousands of sea mounts are to
be detected
next slide please
in the meantime sentinel 6 will
keep continuing this 30-year record
of sea level rise in this plot you see
12 altimeters that have been flying
during the last 30 years
and the pattern that is revealed is
similar between all of them
you see a rise of as much as 9
centimeter
over the last 30 years and we can even
see
a slight increase of the rise
over the last decade
so this mission is going to be very
important for everybody
particularly those in coastal regions
and it's very satisfying for me to have
been
included in this mission i've been
working
for 30 years resettle altimeter data and
the last seven years on central
six so it's a pleasure to see sentinel 6
micro frying be launched
and then after that see the first data
coming out
and george i hope you feel the same
i certainly do thanks rimco uh
thank you also for all your work over
the years i know it's been a long haul
for you
well sentinel 6 what can we say about it
it's the satellite so nice
we built it twice that's right in fact
there are actually two michael freilix
not two michael freilix satellites but
two sentinel 6 satellites
the first one sentinel 6 michael
freilich will launch tomorrow
and in five years from now we'll launch
its successor sentinel 6b
now this is a huge deal for us climate
scientists
because it means we get to look at the
oceans for a full
10 years in an unbroken record and it's
the first time we've been able to build
two in a row
so that we can launch them back to back
and extend the record
much farther than we've been able to so
far now
the record of global sea level rise
actually as
rimco just showed goes back to the early
90s
and what's interesting about it is that
you can see
the rate of rise is actually increasing
so in the 90s
sea level was rising at about two
millimeters per year
in the 2000s it was more like three
millimeters per year
and now it's more like four or close to
five millimeters per year
so we're watching the rate of sea level
rise increase right before our very eyes
and it's satellites like this that allow
us to do it
now the rising ocean is important for
climate change
because over 90 percent of the heat
trapped
by greenhouse gases that we release into
the atmosphere
is actually going into the oceans so we
often think about it as global warming
but really it's ocean warming the oceans
are the really big player in terms
of absorbing heat from the climate
system so
the oceans warm the water expands that's
about one third of sea level rise as
karen mentioned earlier
the rest is from melting glaciers and
ice sheets that are reacting to the
warming environment too
so these missions really give us our
most important yardstick
for measuring climate change and how
it's playing out on the planet
but they don't just measure climate
change in fact this is a huge
impact as craig mentioned hundreds of
millions of people will be affected by
sea level rise in the coming decades
and right now as climate scientists
we're really good at predicting global
warming
but we're not so great at predicting sea
level rise
and our best tool for predicting the
next 10 or 20 or 30 years of sea level
rise
it's what's happening today and what's
happened for the last 10 to 20 to 30
years
so these are really important tools for
climate
and of course the oceans which cover
more than 70 percent of the planet play
a huge role in
many aspects of our climate i think
we'll hear a little bit more about that
later
but in the meantime sentinel 6 also has
a new toy
uh i think we have an animation there's
a sentinel there's a radio occultation
receiver on sentinel 6.
so this uh is an antenna that looks
forward
as the satellite flies around the earth
and as it looks forward it sees
gps satellites coming up above the
horizon
and as they do the signal from the gps
satellite
passes through the earth's atmosphere
and skims off of it
as it does it slows down and the
satellite
measures how much that slowing happens
and that
actually bends around the uh the earth
as you can see
on the rear facing set the rear-facing
antenna right here
now we use that information to actually
figure out the temperature and the
humidity
of the atmosphere not just at one
location but
as a function of height throughout the
atmosphere so you can actually get a
profile
of temperature and humidity which is
really cool
it's really great for numerical weather
prediction and in fact it's so cool i
think i have to put on my
my sunglasses before i introduce our
next speaker which is deirdre byrne
no oceanographer stay cool dear greg
it's climate elvis um
yes so i wanted to talk a little bit
it's obvious it should be obvious to you
guys now that sentinel 6 has a really
important climate mission
but um we're getting the data in real
time and
at noaa we're excited also
about using these data to improve our
real-time ocean products which is
something we call now casting and in
particular i'm going to talk
about the potential to improve
predictions of
hurricane intensification so hurricanes
take energy from the ocean surface
waters a warm ocean under a hurricane
will tend to spin it up and a cool ocean
under hurricane will tend to to dampen
its strength
so sentinel 6 when it's added to the
constellation of satellites already
flying is going to
improve the accuracy of our near surface
ocean heat content products which is
something that comes out every day
and is used by hurricane forecasters so
it's important
for this application to realize that
because sentinel 6 is a radar instrument
it's an active instrument
it can actually see through the clouds
which is a huge advantage for hurricane
work
um now i just want to mention that
hurricanes have always been a big deal
but because of global warming
they're becoming more powerful they're
wetter they're slower moving
they're intensifying more rapidly
they're spinning down more slowly
and now the conditions that spawn
hurricanes are occurring over a larger
area of the ocean so
that makes it even more critical to have
accurate hurricane predictions could i
have my first
image please um so
what i'm showing here is you know people
are becoming aware of this this actually
hit the
um the newspaper the daily newspaper
which was a thrill to me
and the figure on the right is showing
you the upper ocean heat content on
october 7th
as hurricane delta was passing over and
there's a little track there of the
hurricane and as it crossed that red
warm patch
in the caribbean the hurricane spun up
from having a
top uh maximum sustained winds of 20
knots to 120 knots
so that's a really um that's a really
critical tool for us
just it's another you know another tool
in our
in our toolkit for a better hurricane
prediction
um could i have my next image please
and as craig mentioned um ocean surface
roughness and significant wave height
are part of the radar waveform
that come when you're making
measurements of sea level but i want to
emphasize that the significant wave
height is actually
a useful measurement in and of itself so
at noaa's ocean prediction center
forecasters use a significant wave
height to provide marine warnings and
predictions
as real-time data this information is
particularly useful for ship routing
around storms in this picture
this is a screenshot from a forecaster's
actual
screen the forecaster is warning
mariners about
waves reaching between 45 and 57 feet
high in an intense pacific storm so
the real-time data have an essential
mission in protecting
property and saving lives and used in
retrospect significant wave fight is
also useful for things like
risk assessments in the marine insurance
industry
could i have my next figure please
i also wanted to mention that noaa
brings significant
in-water assets to enhance the value of
this mission in particular we maintain a
large network of tide gauges
around the us coast because land can
experience
forces like uplift and subsidence and
erosion
tide gauges are essential to link the
satellite record to what's going on
around the coast
and our other big in-water measurement
system that's
uh critical for the sentinel program is
the argo program
argo pro floats are robotic probes they
drift around in the ocean and they cycle
up and down
making what we call profile measurements
and those profile measurements are an
essential tool
in translating the sea level rise
measured by sentinel 6
into measurements of ocean warming but
they're also essential to the hurricane
prediction tools i mentioned earlier
most recently we've extended these
profiles into the deep ocean with a
program called deep argo
and those probes are being deployed in
areas that have been
seen to be experiencing rapid change in
their deep waters
most of which are polar origin i want to
emphasize argo
is a truly international program with
many many countries participating
and there are currently around 4 000
argo probes in the ocean at the moment
but um the us plays a big role in that i
believe
we've funded about half of those probes
and as you can see here in the
noaa argo lab in seattle we calibrate
the probes and deploy them off our chips
that's the figure on the right
and all in all that program has been a
huge success
and is a is a critical partner to go
along with the
the sentinel 6 satellite and other
altimeters flying
uh could have my next side please
so as um craig already mentioned um
and yeah i want to mention that um noah
and our partners
nasa issa and yumeza operate many kinds
of satellites so we measure ocean color
ocean surface temperatures
ocean winds and these types of
information are synthesized into
products
that we use for ecosystem monitoring we
use for protection tools for harmful
algal blooms
um and we use them to drive ocean models
like the one you can see in the figure
and those models feed into weather
predictions so just having one
additional satellite in the mix is going
to
increase the frequency and density of
sea level measurements available
and in particular that's been shown to
be critical for accurate prediction of
ocean currents and coastal waters so
in addition sentinel 6 is exciting to us
because
it is flying new and better instruments
and there is a possibility of using new
techniques on the data that would get us
information just a little bit closer to
the coast
so it's just a few miles but every
little bit helps
so that's a promising development for
providing more accurate and timely
coastal predictions
so ultimately you know to me the
sentinel 6 missions are exciting because
they're going to allow us to provide
better information to coastal
communities that's 40 of the
u.s population and they're really
experiencing the brunt of a lot of
climate change inundations stronger
hurricanes things like that
and now over to luanne
thanks deirdre so i want to talk to you
about
other applications of sea level to the
study of the ocean's role in climate
both climate variability and change and
in particular the continuity of the
satellite mission is really important
for climate studies because we need to
know
how climate has changed over long
periods especially if we want to know
what controls monthly to year by year
changes in climate so the first example
i want to talk about is el nino
so um go ahead and show the first slide
so many of us have heard about el nino
and it has
impacts all over the globe and it
initiates in the tropical pacific where
the tropical pacific
warms and then that sets off uh
reverberation through the atmosphere
that then impact
areas of the planet that are far from
the tropical pacific
i'm sitting in seattle and right now
we're experiencing a very wet
and cold fall and early winter and you
can see that orange
circle over alaska and the pacific
northwest
that shows drying and warming during el
nino
we are in the middle of a la nina which
is the direct
opposite of el nino during el ninos you
also have
really dry uh weather over indonesia and
the rainforest air and you off
often see very large fires but this is
all coming from
the tropical pacific in that green area
so now we're going to look at
what sea level tells us about what's
going on with the tropical pacific with
the next slide
can you give me the next slide please
there we go so this is sea level
from 2015 to 2016 and you see
this this red which indicates high sea
level
now what does that mean what that means
is that there
is a rise a local rise in sea level and
in fact
it's almost um up to a meter in some
places in the tropical pacific
now that doesn't sound like that much
but it represents a huge amount of heat
in the ocean
if we think about water water can hold a
huge amount of heat and in fact when i
go to bed at night
and my feet are cold i use a hot water
bottle not a hot air bottle
so that to that about a meter or so a
little bit less than a meter of sea
level rise
actually represents warming of the ocean
from the surface down to
several hundred meters several hundred
feet or a hundred meters
that's a huge amount of warm water and
with that warm water
we can tickle that atmosphere or even
push it a little bit
and then see those impacts far from the
tropical pacific
so sea level is really important for
understanding what controls el nino and
la nina and the transitions
and can potentially help help us predict
it
so we're going to go ahead and start
talking about ocean currents
with the next animation so the
other thing about sea level that deirdre
mentioned is that it actually gives us a
really accurate
representative of this representation of
the surface currents in the ocean
so here's an animation of cir surface
currents and you can see
the um gulf of mexico where you see
this big eddy going around and that's
where deirdre was talking about
the impacts of sea level rise on
hurricanes
and then you see the gulf stream coming
up the eastern seaboard of the u.s
and going out into the north pacific i
mean the north atlantic
the really interesting thing about sea
level is that the sea level doesn't ride
downhill i mean the currents don't ride
downhill
they ride along the hill and the steeper
the hill
of sea level the faster the currents so
that animation ended up in my favorite
current the gulf stream which is key to
my research right now
so let's go on to the next slide and
start talking about the ocean's role in
climate and how
it exchanges heat with the atmosphere
now the global warming signal of from
excess carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
gives us about an excess of two watts
per meter squared over the ocean
now if you look over the gulf stream
once again east of the us
you might be able to see that um the
amount of heat that's leaving the ocean
and going to the
atmosphere is two orders of a magnitude
bigger
that's 200 watts per meter squared and
that also represents
uh area of the ocean that has large
variations in sea level
or the heat content of the upper ocean
and with that information of how that
heat content is changing
by observing sea level we can also learn
things about
how we can use this huge heat capacity
of the ocean to actually
understand what controls weather
over europe on time scales from
a month to several years
so sea level these sea level
measurements are not just about what's
going on
around the coast but they also tell us
about
what controls the climate over months to
years
and in particular what the role is for
controlling this climate variability and
change okay i'll send it back to you
marina
thank you so much luanne we are now
ready to take media questions
remember to press star one to get put in
the queue
and please direct your questions to one
of the panelists that we just heard from
we're also taking questions through the
seeing the seas
hashtag on all social media platforms
so right now on the phone we have
elizabeth
howell with space.com welcome elizabeth
hi and thank you so much for taking my
question this is probably for deirdre
if i was a member of the public
following this mission what kind of maps
charts or other data products could i
look forward to for sentinel 6
and also about when will they be
released
well we'll be folding the sentinel 6
data
in with all of the other altimeters in
the in the family so you
you really wouldn't see from our
information products
a special sentinel 6 map
we take in all the available information
and we use it together
which is not to say you can't go get the
sentinel 6 data if you want it
but just from the user end
it'll be folded in
all right thank you so much for that and
now we will head over to the hashtag
seeing the sea social media questions
our first question comes from
caribbean gis on twitter
asking will hashtag sentinel 6 data be
made available
to the public on g or other portals
question
maybe remco can answer this
yeah thank you for the question in fact
if you really want to get to the data
first you need to wait a bit as i
explained we first want to analyze the
data before we're going to release it to
all users
but we do that over the next year we'll
start
that in around six months and all the
products will be available by the end of
the year
um you can get it from umitzat you can
go to the human sub website and find
the earth observation portal the eo
portal and
you set up an account and from that
onwards you can download the data once
it's available
it's very simple and i
you i hope that you all enjoy the
products
also as dear man mentioned of course we
also
distribute this data to other agencies
that don't make their own products
like noaa is doing but also for example
the copernicus marine environmental
monitoring service
cements will be doing ecmwf
the european center for a medium range
weather forecast will be
so settle six will start to be
incorporated in a lot of the user
products that are
created by other agencies as well
and i think that's what makes this
product so amazing is that everybody has
access to it across the globe which is
really incredible we've got our next
question from twitter
from ave valencia and the question is
why is its twin satellite being launched
five years apart would you like to take
that josh
uh yeah thanks for the question um we
need to get
uh as long a record as we can of sea
level we've been measuring sea level
since the early 90s
with these missions and each one has
just barely launched in time before the
next one
has aged and stopped working so
what's amazing about this satellite is
really two things first is that we're
launching it while
our previous satellite jason-3 is still
healthy
and young and then the second is that
we'll have another satellite in five
years
as sentinel 6 michael freilix starts to
age we'll be able to launch
sentinel 6b to take its place and extend
the record a full decade
and as i said before every decade is
like a whole new rate of global sea
level rise that we have to measure
all over again sea level rise isn't
going to go away anytime soon so we have
to keep measuring it
and the longer the record the better
thank you josh next from instagram
cedric asks how long will sentinel 6
operate for karen
as well as its uh its follow-on sentinel
6b
we anticipate we'll live uh about seven
years
so that's how we get to uh by launching
them five years apart that's how we get
to the decade-long
record that that josh just mentioned
great thank you karen and now denzel
on periscope asks what part of the ocean
is covered by this new satellite that
wasn't
before craig would you like to take that
question
it's a really good question the part of
the ocean that has not been covered
before
is the high resolution part of the ocean
which we can get at
by using our synthetic aperture radar
technologies
and this means that we can get down to
just um 300 meters in the along track
direction
and in certain parts of the ocean for
example um
would be in the eastern basins of um
in the southern pacific how a long wave
swell
rolls in from the antarctic uh and the
southern ocean currents
um and we can see that in the in the sar
data
and that hasn't been visible before in
the low resolution measurements
we've had in the past the orbit stays
exactly the same
as the predecessor mission is because as
josh manson and carol mentioned
we need to keep uh our spacecraft in
that orbit
to maintain the same measurements for
the long duration that's how we get the
precision of our sea level measurements
back to you
thank you craig now astro girl on
periscope
asks how much does sea water rise
each and every year luanne would you
like to take that
a few millimeters a year so on
accumulated over
the record we have about nine um
over the last century we have about nine
centimeters of sea level rise
and it's just that sea level rise is
going to continue to accelerate over
time
yes thank you luanne at moon to mars
quest
on twitter asks 2020 has produced a
robust hurricane season in the atlantic
basin
will future active hurricane activity
like
this year's affect the general average
sea height
when compared to the baseline deidre
would you like to take that
um i don't see the
hurricanes affecting the sea level it's
more that a higher sea level
is indicative of more heat that's
available to feed into the hurricanes
so it's the other way around if i got
the question right
yes thank you lakin on twitter
asks what is the deepest sea level
measured so far by the satellites that
have come
before sentinel 6.
josh would you like to take that
sure uh these satellites measure how
tall the ocean is
but they don't and they really tell us
that relative to the center of the whole
planet so
what we're watching is how the oceans
grow over time
if you think about it it's it's really
amazing the
more than 70 of the planet is covered by
oceans
and all of that is rising so we're
literally watching the shape of the
planet
change before our very eyes and that's
what these satellites are really so good
at
thanks marina
thanks so much josh and thank you so
much for media and social media who have
contributed today to this
really awesome briefing we all learned
so very much
thank you for your questions and thank
you to our panelists for joining us here
today
the u.s european sentinel 6 michael
freileck satellite
will launch from vandenberg air force
base tomorrow morning at first attempt
907 am pacific time for more information
on the satellite
go to www.nasa.gov
sentinel 6 and you can also follow us on
all social media platforms
at nasa earth to keep up with this
mission
and all the earth missions that we are a
part of
thanks so much for joining us today at
nasa earth science
your home is our mission thank you for
watching
[Music]
do